did you replace private insurance no I  think the choice is is fundamental to  our ability to get private insurance is  not working for tens of millions of  Americans when you talk about the  co-pays that deductibles the premiums  the out-of-pocket expenses it's not  working that's not working they can  choose Medicare for the questionary  workers in you gotta start acknowledging  the associate is looking for people  they're able to keep them why are you  saying like their private health  insurance by the way it should be noted  that 100 million Americans I mean I  think we should be the party that keeps  what's working and fixes what's broken  [Applause]